the movie begins as a boy named Charlie
Furlong is playing hide and seek with
his friends as he hides inside a cabinet
he accidentally notices his dad getting
intimate with another woman this
petrifies the boy so much that he
becomes temporarily blind ever since
that day Charlie goes blind for 37
minutes if he even thinks about a coitus
even on his honeymoon night he goes
blind which stuns his wife years pass
and we get to know that Charlie's son
Philip has also been cursed with a
strange ability every time he is
frightened or anxious the electrical
appliances near him will stop working 20
years later when Philip's wife goes into
labor she panics and collapses on the
field strangely when her pregnant belly
touches the ground all the greenery
around her starts to wither away in the
next scene Philip eventually arrives at
the scene and drives his wife to the
hospital but along the way he becomes so
scared that the car breaks down this
leaves him with no choice but to deliver
the baby himself Philip uses his
expertise from the cow farm and
successfully rescues his son but
unfortunately his wife is not so lucky
she passes away due to extreme
exhaustion cut to 10 years later we see
the boy whose name is James Furlong
living in the countryside with his dad
and grandmother his grandfather Charlie
died in an accident when he suddenly
turned blind it is revealed that he
accidentally noticed an erotic poser
which rendered his vision useless
realizing that the furlongs have been
cursed James's sweet grandmother always
advises him to be a normal kid and stay
out of trouble but instead of listening
to her he does the exact opposite James
is desperate to discover the
supernatural power within him so he
often partakes in daring stunts one day
he wears a Superman costume and rides
his bicycle at full speed James wants to
check if he can fly and the costume is
totally necessary for this but
unfortunately the bike falls and he ends
up getting injured later his Dad Philip
goes to the farm and discovers that all
of their cows have mysteriously died
coincidentally this is the same spot
where James had crashed earlier ah you
can't fly kid you can only kill cows so
in a fit of rage Philip returns home and
starts scolding his son when the scared
boy hides inside the car James forces
him out and slaps him causing him to
fall to the ground at this moment The
Greenery around James starts to die
before Philip can comprehend what's
happening he experiences excruciating
pain and passes away even poor Grandma
dies a horrible death inside the house
in the aftermath James is forced to move
to an orphanage because he is has always
been pampered and homeschooled he
immediately becomes the subject of
bullying by other kids only one boy
named Liam is kind to him and they
quickly become friends one day as James
is preparing to take a shower the
bullies attack him and throw his soap
out of the window they then force him to
climb down and retrieve it suddenly a
dog approaches James and growls at him
this scares the poor boy so much that he
runs away screaming as far as dropping
the soap goes that could have been worse
the following morning the principle of
the orphanage gathers all the students
and delivers a bombshell herbal of a dog
died under mysterious circumstances last
night the angry principal now blames the
bullies as they are the ones who are
always causing trouble around the place
because of this accusation later the
enraged bullies gang up on James and
start beating him up one of them even
hits the poor boy with a baseball bat
Liam tries his best to stop them but to
no avail just when it appears that James
is going to get killed his superpowers
kick in all the boys around him even
Liam suddenly begin writhing in pain
they collapse to the ground one after
another and pass away James horrified by
what he has done and quickly gets up and
flees the place meanwhile Liam is the
only boy who manages to survive as he
fled the scene in the nick of time
nonetheless he is left with severely
damaged lungs cut to several years later
we see a girl named May at a hospital
she is terminally ill and the doctors
have informed her that it is only a
matter of time before she passes away
not wanting to die in the hospital May
puts on some makeup and sneaks out
outside she runs into Liam who is also
being treated in the same ward it turns
out his damaged lungs have still not
healed properly and they have resulted
in cancer he tries to engage in a
conversation with may but she ignores
him and runs into the nearby Woods after
walking for a few hours she arrives at a
location where all the greenery and
vegetation have died moreover not even a
single trace of animal life is present
there at the same time it begins so may
rushes to a nearby cabin she knocks on
the door and the person who opens it is
none other than James it is revealed
that ever since the incident at the
orphanage James has isolated himself
from the rest of the world fearing that
he may kill more people even in this
instance he tells May to go away and
slams the door on her face but when she
begs to be led inside as it is raining
he reluctantly agrees that night James
lets me sleep in his cabin this is the
first time in years he is interacting
with another human the following morning
they have a little chat realizing that
James is nervous May hands over her
Walkman to him James promptly puts on
the headphones and listens to some music
he is immediately overwhelmed with
emotions as he hasn't heard anything
other than the forest in years to return
the favor James cooks or Emil which she
finds very tasty later May decides to
take a swim in a nearby lake James
brings her a towel but becomes
embarrassed when he sees her semi-naked
after a while the two sit for another
round of chat and may shares about her
condition James who has been isolated
from the outside world for too long and
doesn't even know what cancer is
nonetheless he hopes that she can
recover as soon as possible the two then
stare at the beautiful sky and spend
some hours there in the next scene May
finally decides to return to the
hospital so she bids James goodbye and
departs after a few minutes James
realizes that she has forgotten her
Walkman he rushes out to give it back
but in his haste slips and falls down a
hill as James is knocked unconscious the
vegetation around him starts to die
fortunately Mei arrives at the scene and
tends to his injuries she promptly wakes
him up and starts walking him back to
his cabin James who is bleeding slightly
is shocked to learn that may is not hurt
it's almost as if she is immune to his
powers on the other hand May's mom and
the authorities finally start looking
for her Liam directs them towards the
woods and a massive search begins when
may hears her Mom calling from a
distance she quickly hides inside a tree
with James the latter wants her to
return to her mom and continue her
treatment but may doesn't want to leave
James alone as he is injured at this
point it is evident that both of them
have fallen in love with each other this
same night after returning to the cabin
May tries to help James with his wounds
but he keeps distancing himself from her
when asked what's the matter James
finally reveals his condition he recalls
the past where he accidentally killed
his family an innocent dog and then
several Boys in an orphanage James
further reveals that when he escaped the
orphanage he was very young so he didn't
know how to take care of himself he
impulsively ate a wild berry in the
woods and got sick fortunately a hunter
rescued him before he starved to death
the hunter then brought him to this
cabin and took care of him like his own
son James time and time again warned the
hunter to stay away from him but to no
avail then one day the inevitable
happened when James got out of the cabin
he saw the Hunter's lifeless body on the
ground this devastated him so much that
he made the decision to isolate himself
from the rest of the world hearing all
this may sympathizes with James as she
realizes that he has become the victim
of his own powers that he then spent the
cold night together where James offers
his jacket to May in the morning when he
wakes up he realizes that she has
already laughed surprise surprisingly
when James gets out of the cabin he
discovers some living plants and even
Birds meanwhile May finds her way back
to the hospital and lies that she got
lost while trying to catch some fresh
air however Liam eventually finds out
the truth when he spots James's red
jacket he warns her about the boy saying
James is a dangerous person but may does
not want to listen enraged Liam heads
outside and explains everything to the
cops when they don't believe him either
Liam throws a tantrum so bad that he has
to be sedated a few days later James
sneaks inside the hospital looking for
the love of his life he accidentally
sees Liam though but the latter is too
weak to move shortly after James finally
reaches May's room and they end up
having intercourse that night the next
morning something miraculous happens all
the sick and diseased people in the
hospital start getting healed the blinds
start to see the handicapped start
walking and the cancer patients are no
longer in danger even Liam is cured of
his lung infection and all James had to
do was get laid using this opportunity
Liam grabs scissors and starts looking
for James hoping to to get revenge on
the other hand is all the patients are
out in the hallway May puts a gown on
James and the two follow the crowd
unfortunately along the way they get
separated it is at this moment Liam
finally spots James and starts blaming
him for the past incident in a fit of
rage he chases James outside the
hospital where the two get into a tussle
sadly amidst the tussle James is stabbed
in the stomach the moment he starts
bleeding everything around him starts to
wither away here we get to know that
James's special powers are influenced by
his mood if he is happy or lucky
everything around him starts to Blossom
but when he is sad or scared only bad
things happen realizing what he has done
Liam quickly runs away from there and at
the same time may also arrives scared
that he might end up killing her as well
James runs away and dives into a river
may also jumps in as he doesn't know how
to swim she holds him underwater and
kisses him passionately but by this time
poor James is already dead as he slowly
drowns into the depths of the river The
Greenery around him begins to rise again
James's death finally brings in to the
mysterious Furlong Family the movie then
cuts to five years later where May is
seen reciting a story to a little girl
she is none other than May and James's
daughter and she's probably gonna cause
a lot of people to die subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching